[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 el
feminismo enfrenta continuas discusiones
sobre cómo deben defenderse los derechos
humanos un tema neurálgico es la
prostitución mientras que hay colectivos
que abogan por la legalización de la
prostitución las iniciativas
abolicionistas niegan que se trate de un
oficio y la incluyen como una modalidad
de explotación sexual de las mujeres
para las voces que hablarán hoy mientras
exista una mujer cuyo cuerpo pueda ser
comprado por el hecho de ser mujer habrá
discriminación
uno de los problemas que enfrentamos
cuando abordamos este fenómeno de la
prostitución es la discusión sobre la
legalidad que si bien es vista por
muchos o como una suerte de lucha contra
el tráfico humano es para otros una
justificación para cometer crímenes con
protección para la postura en contra
abolir es la única solución
prostitución se dice popularmente que es
el oficio más antiguo del mundo pero es
realmente un oficio las mujeres
abolicionistas dicen no y se resguardan
en el derecho internacional expresado en
la convención de 1979 sobre la
eliminación de todas las formas de
discriminación contra la mujer contra
los movimientos en diversos países
promueven la legalización del llamado
trabajo sexual como un ejercicio laboral
ellas argumentan que el pago por sexo es
una violación de los derechos humanos y
que lejos de ser una decisión vocacional
constituye un sistema criminal de
explotación sexual trata de personas
coacción a través del dinero y abuso de
poder contra las mujeres y las niñas uno
de los principios fundamentales es que
las personas no son mercancías o cosas
para ser usadas son un fin no un medio y
esa visión determina que la prostitución
no es algo que la mujer hace sino algo
que se le hace capa internacional la
coalición por la abolición de la
prostitución está conformada por 14 ongs
que promueven asistencia a las personas
prostituidas y a las víctimas de trata
de seres humanos
de prostitución la organización señala
en su informe de 2016 que prostituir es
un obstáculo fundamental para la
igualdad entre hombres y mujeres y cita
entre decenas de documentos el convenio
de naciones unidas- del 2 de diciembre
de 1949 para la represión de la trata de
personas y de la explotación según el
cual la prostitución es incompatible con
la dignidad y el valor del ser humano lo
que abocó a un combate contra el
proxenetismo en todas sus formas así
como a la ayuda para las personas
prostituidas lucha que mantienen hasta
hoy
vamos a hablar del tema y para eso nos
acompaña a claudia quintero defensora de
derechos humanos y directora de la
corporación anne frank dedicada al
activismo por los derechos y la paz
claudia gracias por estar con nosotros
en ellas hoy
no gracias a ti por la invitación y aquí
estoy
bueno claudia usted es una activista una
mujer que defiende que la prostitución
es lo mismo que explotación sexual
usted va en contra de este tema
precisamente porque piensa o dice que la
prostitución es contraria al feminismo
háblenos de eso
yo soy una mujer
acción humilde afrocolombiana y aprendí
que el feminismo realmente tiene que ir
a la raíz de la opresión
la opresión hacia la mujer va hacia el
cuerpo de la mujer cuando uno compra un
objeto o compra un servicio el cliente
manda y en la compra del cuerpo como
podríamos decir que somos feministas
graves defender que el cliente que
mayormente son varones sean que mande
durante un momento de un pago no
entonces este es el feminismo al cual
preocuparte que quizás no se aprende en
academias sino en la calle con las
mujeres que sobreviven de la
prostitución y con las mujeres en
situación de prostitución bueno claudia
porque no es suficiente prohibir porque
no es lo mismo prohibir que abolir la
prostitución
justamente él
estas personas que están de acuerdo con
hacer ver la constitución como un
trabajo y no como una situación a la
cual cualquier mujer podría llegar
realmente confunden al decir que abolir
es prohibir nosotras realmente lo que
abogamos es por los derechos humanos de
las mujeres cuando las mujeres tienen
derechos humanos
no hay tanta constitución mira que
porque hay trata de personas porque el
mercado de la constitución entonces
satisface por sí solo es decir hoy yo no
se hace prostituta y con todo el respeto
y cariño que tengo que tampoco me todas
las mujeres que están hoy en el canal
quieren ser prostitutas por eso es que
se necesita de la trata de personas para
suplir este mercado porque la
prostitución no es el oficio más antiguo
del mundo sino un privilegio masculino y
por eso justamente quienes más abogan
por este tema son los hombres
y entonces no podemos decir que porque
hay dos o tres personas que dirán yo
deseo esto yo es el otro esto ya se
convierte en un derecho el único derecho
aquí que tienen las mujeres una vida
libre de violencias ya que justamente
esta brecha y estas desigualdades que la
llevaron esta pistola simbólica que son
esas condiciones previas que favorecen
que las mujeres lleguen a esta situación
sean abolidas para clay si muy poquitas
muy poquitas van a querer estar en la
prostitución y tenemos estas condiciones
claudia las organizaciones que están a
favor de legalizar lo que ellos
denominan como trabajo sexual dicen que
esta es una forma de entregarles a las
mujeres derechos laborales ustedes dicen
que no porque esto no se trata de
derechos laborales sino de derechos
humanos explíquenos por favor esa
diferencia tan fundamental para ustedes
y tú te acuerdas que en colombia tuvimos
un par de pilotos para ser piloto hay
que tener plata hay que estudiar
no se les reconoció en sus derechos
laborales tres tiempo corre [__] en la
calle que se desayunan con cerveza que
la gran presión es que sus traumas son
similares retiraron la guerra no se les
va a dar derechos laborales por eso es
que esta lucha en muy pocas
sobrevivientes por eso es que a mí me
han querido matar porque son muy muy
pocas las campo hemos podido sobrevivir
y estamos haciendo un ejercicio político
en este tema dos o tres estrellitas
porque salgan diciendo en los medios de
comunicación que ellas son trabajadoras
sexuales no es prohibir a la
constitución en colombia para que paguen
impuestos pero no podemos decirle a esa
mujer que estaba en el bromo que
nosotros fuimos las que las ayudamos a
rescatar esas mujeres que están en el
barrio santafé esos migrantes
venezolanas que están en la calle ven a
esta trabajadora pague impuestos esto es
una barbaridad eso es inhumano
no no
fueron [__] por la situación que
arreció hacia ellas
yo abajo por esta inmensa mayoría
entonces la prostitución razón del otro
colegio la que hace deporte puede ser
[__] nadie le está diciendo que no
nosotros lo que estamos pidiendo es
acabar con las causas estructurales por
eso creemos que primero necesitamos
derechos humanos nos lamentamos mentiras
a la gente no le metamos falsas
diciéndoles que les vamos a dar derecho
laborales cuando en colombia lo que
reina es el contrato a prestación de
servicios y lo que reina es el desempleo
eso es una navidad
hablemos entonces de su activismo del
otro lado cómo es su trabajo para darle
refugio y apoyo a las mujeres que desean
salir de este círculo y que ya no desean
ser prostituidas
es muy chiquito realmente lo que yo hago
es muy poquito frente al fenómeno pero
pues acá llegó a los 2 años
luchando la sufrido muchísimas amenazas
pero por lo menos podemos contar varios
logros que me gustaría contarte porque
mira que estas personas que dicen
defender a las supuestas demente
trabajadoras sexuales nunca han metido
un precedente a la cárcel
una red de trata de personas porque es
que uno no podría con los amigos
perdóname yo soy muy fuerte en esto y la
verdad es así y también nosotras y el
poco trabajo que hemos hecho es lograr
por ejemplo en la primera condena por
trata de personas contra el clan del
golfo ya estamos luchando por una
condena contra un tratante de una mujer
llamada tan infinita que estuvo cinco
años en la cárcel por escapar de un
prostíbulo porque un fiscal pensó que
esa no era una víctima sino que era una
trabajadora
y lesionó a un empresario entonces ahí
está la visión y ahí está el daño que
esta visión le está haciendo a las
víctimas los jueces y los fiscales no
nos ven como víctimas sino como
trabajadoras entonces ese es el trabajo
que hacemos tenemos un proyecto en
popayán una casa refugio
trabajamos en incidencia y mostrado con
población en situación de migrante de
migración y pues realmente sí soy muy
molesta porque falta mucho por hacer
creo que lo máximo que logramos digamos
que hemos logrado es llegar a la corte
constitucional y que sea la primera vez
que una sobreviviente de la prostitución
pueda decirle a esos nueve magistrados
que en definitiva sen parte del poder en
colombia
escuche estado trabados
tiene pocos medios quizás poquísimos y
ustedes nos han abierto este escenario
escucha esta voz
ustedes han denunciado desde desde la
posición abolicionista que existe un
lobby internacional que lo que hace es
animar la prostitución o el abuso de
estas mujeres como ustedes le llaman
cuáles son estas organizaciones porque
usted dice que esto no es filantropía
sino que es animar los crímenes
que no estamos peleando contra el suelo
de la esquina realmente
yo tengo medidas extraordinarias estado
refugiada nosotros tristes porque esto
sí la apropiación del trabajo sexual
porque nos amenazan entonces ahí es
donde empezamos a descubrir yo no
podemos señalar organizaciones pero sí
puedo decir que
este negocio produce 150 mil millones de
dólares al año y eso desactualizada esa
cifra dicha por la organización
internacional del trabajo entonces es
una ecuación de muchísima plata andrea
que sólo en nuestro exceso aportan 99
mil millones de dólares a esta industria
entonces no estamos
a cualquier punto un juego sino que
estamos realmente en contra un monstruo
que es la industria del sexo que produce
muchísima muchísima plata a través de la
explotación sexual y cuando la mayoría
de la explotación sexual que más produce
plata en las niñas y los niños eso es
bastante doloroso lo que vemos de
mujeres adultas es es muy triste y es
doloroso y es gigante pero lo que
tenemos es producción de niños y niñas
es aún si ustedes vieran todos los
reportes que nosotras tenemos que
recibir a diario realmente quedarían
asombrados de esta situación
claudia gracias a usted por contarnos
esta parte de realidad
este activismo que usted realiza todos
los días en las calles de colombia en
este caso y bueno simplemente para la
reflexión en uno de los grupos
poblacionales que más corre peligro de
ser asesinados son las mujeres en
prostitución gracias a ustedes por estar
con nosotros en ellas hoy volvemos
próximamente
[Música]